[Music]
Maryann is in Jackson Michigan hi
Maryanne how are you hi Dave better than
I deserve thank you for taking my call
certainly how can I help not very
responsible with money she's had a lot
of secret credit cards and secretly for
a secret friend my dad having trouble
hearing you on your phone can you stand
still and speak directly into it please
yes ma'am thank you all right so as a
child my mom had access to money bank
accounts and several times my fingers
account would go to zero because she was
just borrow money from it will take
money out of it my sister a cognitive
disability and has just been approved
for Social Security income and I am
worried that my mom is not going to be
responsible with that money so your mom
is your mother is responsible for your
sister yeah she fillings at home okay
all right and your question is what my
question is my husband and I eventually
will probably be the pays for this
situation or like when my mom can't make
decisions but I'm wondering if there's
any way that I can like talking alone
and get something set up where we're one
time that they offer that or something I
just don't want you know that the only
way that that would happen would be if
your mother or whoever the guardian is
would approve that okay and if she
approves it you can designate the right
you could designate the payee to be
whoever you want but everybody that's
involved has to agree right and your
sister is not in the equation because of
a cognitive disability means she does
not make this
visions okay yeah yeah she's legally not
able to make the decision on the payee
so your mother and father are in the
driver's seat as her caregiver and
unless they relinquish that to you
voluntarily there's nothing you can do
okay unless you went in and did an
extremely violent court battle and
declared your parents your and parents
to be completely incompetent and to be a
thief and everything else and and then
the judge would just remove them as her
caregiver and remove them from her you
know her effective power of attorney you
can check an attorney but that's what
they'll tell you in this situation okay
so it's a it's a matter of there's
really no middle ground a violent court
action which I really would not
recommend I mean your mother's not a
very likable character in this story so
far but but she's not to the point that
I'm ready to violently remove her by
correction by violently I don't mean
physical violence I mean the legal the
legal process is visceral and so you
know ask an attorney get some advice on
that but that's my understanding of what
you're facing and you know you decide
what you're going to do is so really if
you're not going to go that route which
you're probably not then the only thing
left to you is the only possible thing
left to you is is talk to your dad and
say you know mom's pretty much stolen
everything over the years she doesn't
mean to be a thief but effectively
that's what she's done because she's so
freakin out of control dad you have to
agree with that statement yes daughter I
know I know about your mom okay then you
guys sign over the payee will man you
take care of my sister and we'll manage
her money so mom doesn't steal it and if
you can persuade dad your mom's not
gonna like it but if you can persuade
diet to may get his wife to do this then
that's gonna be the best thing for your
sister based on the story you told me
because your mother is gonna steal this
money a hundred percent she's gonna
steal this money you can count on
I'm sorry but that's our track record if
you steal your eight-year-old savings
account the pretty mo makes you scum
okay this is the Dave Ramsey show